Aww yeah! Get ready for another fun English
lesson with Taylor Swift.
In this video we are featuring a clip from her new
Netflix documentary Miss Americana.
I feel really good about not feeling
muzzled anymore and it was my own doing
There's nothing that feels better than
this moment
And then we will break down part of her
hit song Lover.
And just let you know if you're new here
every week we make fun lessons with your
favorite movies TV, series songs and more
so that you can understand fast speaking
natives without getting lost without
missing the jokes and without subtitles
Génesis says that we're helping her in
her dream to work on airplanes and we'll
help you to reach your English learning
goals too just hit the subscribe button
and the bell down below so you don't
miss any of our new lessons
So you can learn a ton by doing the things
you love like watching series like
Friends and movies like Frozen but is it enough?
Well in my experience learning
six different languages I have always
found that native media and keeping it
fun are essential parts of the process
but sooner or later I would always get
stuck and this made me lack confidence
because I knew I was making mistakes but
I didn't really know what I needed to
focus on learning to correct them and my
friends weren't correcting me and they
didn't really know either how to explain
the grammar to me. So at some point just
music, books and series aren't enough. You
need the guidance of a teacher, so for me
having the guidance of a professional
who has tons of experience helping
people who are having the same learning
challenges is essential and that's why I
am excited to present a great new
opportunity from our friends over at Lingoda
they are going to help you to
improve your speaking skills and your
confidence quickly in just a matter of
months and the great part about this
promotion is that when you fully
participate in all the classes you can
get a 100% refund so I've tried Lingoda and it is fantastic! You get to learn
with native teachers anytime you want
and they give you all the materials you
need so you know exactly what you need
to focus on so over the past few years
Lingoda had 20,000 learners just
like you to transform their lives
getting opportunities to work and study
abroad. You can see some of their
inspiring stories on Lingoda's website
by clicking the link down below and
definitely check out their Instagram as
well.
So, what exactly is this promotion?
So Lingoda has a motivating study
challenge called the Sprint and this is
really fantastic because it gets you
committed to learning as both a coach
and a live language learning myself I
know that having this
accountability is absolutely crucial because it's
otherwise it's too easy to skip when
you're tired or busy and with the Super
Sprint you will be showing up every
single day and you're going to make huge
progress on your learning unless you do
this sprint in which you do slightly
less classes now when you complete all
of the classes in the super sprint and
you will be getting a 100% refund and if
you complete the Sprint's you'll get a
50% refund.
It's open to all levels
whether you're a beginner and
intermediate or advanced and as a bonus
you will have free access to the
Cambridge online language test.
The sprint begins on April 8th and ends on
July 6th.
Alright so in order to
participate you have to sign up before
March 24th after paying your 49 euro
non-refundable deposit fee which holds
your spots you will automatically be
signed up for a three-month subscription
but don't worry this deposit goes
towards paying your first month of
classes and remember that Lingoda
refund 100% of your tuition fee if you
complete the agreed number of classes
there's no trick or catch here but be
sure to read all of the terms and
conditions as students say that this is
the key to success in the Sprint and to
make it even better for you we have a
special discount code for you just click
the link down in the scription box below
and use our code to get 10 euros off of
your entry fee now if you already have
good habits learning English with TV
series and other native media then I
think Lingoda's spring can be a really
awesome opportunity for you. Just imagine
if in three months you could confidently
converse with a native or get an
exciting new job or move to another
country and you could do it all for free
by completing Lingoda Sprint best of
luck to all of you that participate in
the Sprint and now let's get back to
this lesson with Taylor Swift.
If you love Taylor Swift
well we have a ton of lessons teaching
you English with her in this playlist
you can check that out after you finish
this video by clicking up here or down
in the description below
All right well now I recommend that you
listen to that song over and over and
over again trust me it's going to do a
lot for your English pronunciation and
it's a lot of fun and if you want to
know how you can learn English with any
song you want be sure to check out this
video over here and now it's time to go
beyond classroom and live your English!
Aww yeah!